[Musique]
c'est quoi ça c'est des petits pois
dans un sandwich sur une soupe ou une
salade ces aliments met dans l'assiette
du verre même en hiver pourtant comme
nous l'écrit santé canada il peut y
avoir certains risques pour la santé les
germes ont été associés à des éclosions
de maladie au canada les micropousses
peuvent être contaminés par des
microorganismes dangereux
leur consommation peut entraîner des
risques d'intoxication alimentaire
comme pour tous les aliments frais
quelques règles de base elle soyez
rassurés leur consommation peut demeurer
sécuritaire en notant que les
consommateurs sauf quelques
recommandations
25 ans les achats à l'épicerie est
important de miser sur les produits
luxueux et croustillant c'est un type
d'aliment qu'on invite les consommateurs
à acheter mais de manière à les
consommer très rapidement on fermes lufa
une grande partie des serres est occupée
par la culture des pouces la demande est
croissante on a les petits pois comme
celui là on en est là net on a les radis
brocoli duquel la lucerne l'herbe de blé
ma favorite celle ci l'a trop si on veut
rajouter de la saveur de la texture et
même des nutriments les micropousses est
probablement la meilleure chose
particulièrement pour les personnes qui
ont de la misère à rajouter des légumes
dans l'alimentation c'est très bien
c'est très facile à utiliser simplement
le coupé le lave et le mettre dans toute
la nourriture
importante différence les germinations
se développe dans l'eau alors que les
micropousses son sommet dans un terreau
ou un autre substrat comme de la joute
ici par exemple des gens commencent à
voir les premiers feuilles ce qui sort
et si vous voyez les racines commence à
passer à travers le jute
les gerbes c'est vraiment quand le grain
il est à peine il vient de se casser et
on commence à voir la petite racine sas
et légère à micropousses c'est quand on
commence déjà à voir la petite plante
qui sort
les boys ok d'accord
une fois elles sont prêtes sessad donc
annoncer ou comme ça c'est comme des
cheveux il faut les couper ça me gêne
vraiment beaucoup le fait qu'il soit
vivant cru les poussées germination sont
de véritable concentré de saveurs et
d'éléments nutritifs malgré cela santé
canada suggère tout de même de faire
cuire les germinations surtout pour les
gens à risque
- les germes je les prends somme aurait
pas cru précisément parce que c'est
vraiment dans une environnement la
manière de le faire pousser c'est très
humide c'est parfait pour que certaines
bactéries qui peuvent causer de dommages
chez les humains soient présents il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui ne les font
pas cuire ils vont vraiment quand même
ville bien les laver
à micropousses c'est comme une laitue
donc si on le coup qu'on ne mange pas
les grains et qu on les lave
correctement ces communes les pieds en
cuisine pas nécessairement la lecture à
votre connaissance parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de rappel beaucoup
d'intoxication alimentaire directement
relié au germination et au pouce depuis
2010 est toutes les données colligées ne
montre qu'un seul événement donc ça
démarre très faible
ce que l'eau est recyclée pour les
microbes poussant les recycle non ce
n'est le plus de nok précisément pour
toutes les questions de bactéries t
exactement
celui de radis c'est un de mes favorites
ça goûte un radis on peut prendre
seulement un petit petites feuilles de
microbes rousset salle goûtant radicaux
on est loin des simples fait germer dans
le tube si oui celle-là c'est celle de
korian
ça c'est ma favorite je le mets partout
toutes les recettes qui ont besoin de la
coriandre moi je m'épate l'accord est
normal je mets des les micropousses
je trouve que la demande est en
croissance mais ça va toujours varié
dépendamment de la période de l'ain
l'été puisqu'il ya tellement de choses
vertes un peu partout mais personne pour
moins se pencher sur les micropousses
tandis que l'hiver puisqu'il ya moins de
trucs frais on vend vraiment des
quantités incroyables de microbes aux
[Musique]
auparavant réservée aux magasins
d'aliments naturels on les trouve
maintenant dans de nombreuses épiceries
si on veut le conserver vivant on peut
le laisser un peu au frigo aussi parce
que de la même manière ça va conserver
un peu mais à la meilleure chose c'est
de le laisser proche d'une fenêtre ça va
continuer à pousser un tout petit peu
trop manger vous oui c'est quoi votre
préféré la luzerne par les germes fip
attaque les pousses de radis au niveau
des micropuces si on va manger chez vous
qu'est ce que vous faites comme clos
puisque c'est quoi les micropousses vous
été déçu
une numéro 7 avec micropousses favorite
c'est le tartare de saumon en tartare de
saumon avec une micropuce dan est
une tendance d'une lime les gens ils
produisent à la maison de plus en plus
c'est intéressant
si ça peut être une belle activité à
faire avec les enfants tout sommet il ya
vraiment des précautions à prendre la
semoule
faut vraiment faire très attention si on
va faire des germes est précisément
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'humidité c'est
là où il est c'est un processus un petit
peu différente mais pour les
micropousses on peut le faire à la
maison ça s'apprend pas beaucoup d
espace cette très nutritive on peut
choisir les variétés qu'on aime et ça
pousse très vite contre 7 jours et qu'un
jour et on a nos petits pour manger